un peu quand même dites-moi des défauts
elle a commencé à l'âge de 3 ans
dans une pub à 9 ans elle était à
l'école du spectacle à 13 ans elle
allait seul à son premier casting ça
c'est fort
et là vraiment Virginie à fond
le loyer
[Rires]
Virginie vous êtes prête vous faites
quoi là je vais vous tester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est Thierry Ardisson est capable
d'expliquer on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
non c'est Guy Bedos bon alors allons-y
c'est tout simplement c'est une
interview psy c'est pour savoir quel est
votre état physique après une semaine en
bas
pour savoir quel est votre état
psychique après une semaine de promotion
sur la plage est-ce que vous êtes
dépressive non est-ce que vous êtes
névrosé
dans quel circonstance
plusieurs quand votre Jules tourne avec
Leonardo DiCaprio vous êtes un peu ouais
je le vis très mal
en même temps
est-ce que vous êtes alors ça c'est très
drôle est-ce que vous êtes porno FOB
tu sais ce que c'est porno folle
pas supporter le porno c'est la première
que je vois qui connaissait conne ou
quoi
vous allez tout trouver là parce que
c'est du grec ancien vous allez voir
est-ce que vous êtes sado
ça peut m'arriver ouais
c'est pas nécessaire
est-ce que vous êtes sac à dos
je suis surtout sac à dos surtout
est-ce que vous êtes maso Virginie
Ledoyen aussi mais ça va te perdre
généralement quand c'est minime
à un peu quand même dites la vérité là
j'ai la réponse
elle aime bien être avec des hommes un
peu plus mûres c'est
sexuels fétichiste
[Rires]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes kenoble ah je sais
moi ça
sérieux je sais en plus
elle a peur du mari de Barbie
[Applaudissements]
c'est celle qui a peur de l'obscurité
s
[Rires]
entre nous
est-ce que vous êtes un héros de
homophobe
non non
la peur des avions
de homophobe
homophobe c'est les gens qui ont peur du
train vraiment
on adore la noix de coco
non pas du tout non
pas du tout
ça se termine bien
sérieusement avec ce test tu crois
vraiment que tu as découvert des choses
sur moi
je le crois très sérieusement et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu